we got the secret Invasion trailer we
got the Blue Beetle trailer we got the
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer now we got the one that we know
the citizens of the reject Nation have
really been waiting for but before that
today's video is sponsored by enthusiasm
ourselves
trailer and it's a teaser trailer numero
dos I can't wait I am so intrigued
ladies and gentlemen
leave a like would you
come on Johnny let's go party
Land There It Is confirmation
it's gonna remain walking hi Barbie
what's up hi Ken
[Music]
hi Ken
uh I thought I might stay over tonight
why because we're girlfriend boyfriend
you do what
I'm actually not sure
it's so funny
earnest
wow
yeah
he's doing here I'm coming with you
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
[Laughter]
ah looks like this beach is a little too
much Beach for you can if I wasn't
severely injured I would beat you off
right now oh no beach off with you any
day Ken anyone who wants to beach him
off has to beat me off first I will beat
both of you off at the same time
nobody's gonna beat anyone off
hahaha
[Music]
oh my most anticipated movie of the year
it's gonna be a treat we gotta think
about this for just a second guys we got
to think about our journey of how
amazing this looks first we hear about a
Barbie movie and you're like I know what
this is going to be
warm rotors whatever and then suddenly
you hear about who's directing it and
you go okay that's bid odd that person
brings a lot of nuance and layers to
their movies first like Cinema then you
hear about who's who's gonna be starring
and Ryan Gosling as Ken then you see the
trailer and it's 2001 it's face
obviously with toys and you see a second
trailer and it's nothing like the first
trailer yeah and they still don't even
really tell you what the plot is based
off of a plot that supposedly was like
put I don't know if it's a leak I don't
know if it's confirmed it seems like
that's what's present here in the
trailer Barbie is living in Barbie land
a bunch of Barbies it looks amazing and
she has to venture off to the real world
the one rumor is that because she has
some imperfections but then she
discovers in the real world that I don't
know some about like comes from
a perfectionism exists
you know perfect being all your life now
here we are that trailer was brilliant
to me watching what Ryan Gosling is
doing here especially because he's
talked about how he's essentially said
Ken's a loser I don't know if he said
those exact words but he said that
several times and no one wants to play
with Ken there's sort of this
self-deprecating way of how he's talked
about the treatment of Ken and this
trailer leans into that out of all the
Kents seems like he's the one who gets
the short in the stick he's a little bit
dumb he's a little bit naive Barbie
doesn't seem that into him and he he
seems a bit like a loser in this trailer
I love it well it seems like they're
leading into that yeah like he's like
kind of like a petty Jealous Guy
especially around all the other kids it
seems like him and see milio especially
are just gonna have like a constant back
and forth game of one upsmanship always
going down the Lego movie has been a
touchstone for this in the past but I
love the way that they imbue that sort
of innocence of how you would play with
the dolls like Barbie and Ken come with
a domestic sort of suggested lifestyle
that also is like completely innocuous
in the hands of a child so I love that
whole thing about like you want to come
over spend the night and do what I don't
know yeah you know yeah it's like it's
so innocent but it's also clearly
knowing what we're all thinking in the
back of its mind and so there's this you
know interesting medicine Sheen about it
which I think is very fitting for the
here and now and also for again you know
I think Barbie has to be unless we're
talking straight to DVD a little smarter
you know than it appears on the outside
and I think the new log line is
something about like you're a perfect
being in a perfect world unless you're
having an existential crisis or you're a
Ken
so Barbie existential crisis and then
Ken yeah yeah and he seems like he's a
big co-dependent on her and I think
having uh this an inappropriate
naativity irreverent sexual humor is
really fitting for Barbie you know
because of especially the kind of
conversations that have circulated
around Barbie and a lot of the kind of
what I mean hopefully no real little
kids are watching this trailer reaction
but you know I I especially growing up
the little I remember being kids and
you'd hear about like hey you're taking
a poor button doesn't have any body
parts
yeah yeah absolutely and then they're
making these jokes about like beats you
off and stuff or even just like little
things of like her feet just staying in
that position because they're always
shaped to be in high heels
designed for Tarantino it was
Tarantino's dream come to life right
look out and speaking of dream this
looks like a dream I love the production
design of this oh sure these colors pop
it is wonderfully Vivid so imaginative
and I just noticed the Wizard of Oz
imagery at the movie theater in the
background which is perfect for this
fantasy Wonderland that we are stepping
into right now this looks so cool well
there's so many like cameos as other
Barbies and things like that and even
Will Ferrell back as Lord Business yeah
with her having the elf-like movie plot
yeah exactly like this is fascinating to
me too because you know the time in
which Barbie would have been introduced
as a toy just in culture in general is
also a time where you don't you know
necessarily acknowledge as many adult
things as we do now so I wonder if
that's gonna play into this too well you
know one thing it sounds a little weird
to say Ryan Gosling
you know let's we gotta face facts here
I'm in love with Ryan Gosling every
everyone should know this about me I'm
absolutely in love with this man I would
leave everyone I'd slaughter a village
of children if it meant get him to spend
the rest of my life with Ryan Gosling
that's true what does it say about Ryan
Gosling who's willing to spend the rest
of his life with a guy who would
slaughter a village of children
that means
he thinks about his heart first that's
right he just knows when someone's gonna
matter about his past actions he would
care about who I am today as long as you
love me baby I don't care who you are
where you're from or what you did but
he's he's older now he's a much older
person and everyone else they cast here
is
looks like aesthetically very very young
young Ryan Gosling you could tell like
he's he's a much older guy now and I
wonder if they're going to lean into
that in some way with Ken or are they
just gonna have him I don't know if
they're what they really deal with age
in this movie if anybody needs to be
able to accept Aging in Hollywood it's
men
no I'm not going but you know what I
mean Ryan Gosling does not look like as
young as a lot of the other cast members
who are living in Barbie land he does
come across like a guy trying to appear
younger than he actually is yeah sure
and the way that like even though it's
like it's part of the aesthetic the very
sort of distinct color palette like even
his hair just kind of looks like an old
guy trying to be young
he he looks like the villain in the
first Blade Runner movie yeah you have
tears and rain
I love the sets I love how uh you can
tell a lot of like the matte painting
wallpaper backgrounds for a lot of it
and a lot of it looks like real
buildings as well I think yeah fake
waves and stuff like yeah the artifice
is great they did an exceptional job
here sure
um I can't wait for that yeah this feels
like it's going to be a very meta film
but also have some type of sociological
sociological yeah sure why not social
commentary yeah
socio-political
paleontology commentary that's right
it's gonna answer some Cosmic questions
for us the meaning of life all right
guys well leave your thoughts down below
this movie looks like an absolute blast
of a time what did you think subscribe
hey let's send this with a
Tyler Hague we could shout out a woman
today but I said no who really reminds
me of a doll I'd want to own and play
with oh sure you I would love to have a
doll of you Tyler
and just stretch you out like in the
split positions
put you with another doll and be like hi
I'm Tighter and then I I'm also Tyler oh
my God I have a secret cursive uh
homosexuality only with myself yes I
will I would only want to be gay for me
it's the age of God
and have you two make out these two
Tyler dolls but then oh no a woman comes
into this correct no oh my God what do I
do oh no but am I gay or for myself or
do I love this wolf
this is a real American drama it's all
good this is beautiful shout out of the
year keep going I want to see this movie
that that would be the Tyler Hague story
yeah really would that be that would be
the best I mean we should mass produce
these dolls so that people can know the
joys too gay for yourself you should be
or do you follow true love in the header
way which one is it going to be just be
Polly for yourself and your your true uh
baby love that would be so interesting
what a weird Twisted Netflix show that
would be about your life of like what if
what if like they were married like he's
married but then he falls in love with a
clone of himself and then it's like why
why is she jealous why is the wife
jealous it's just just another reason
there's no difference between the two if
you love me you should love him fake
story this was a test you failed I want
a divorce
all righty well thank you guys
love you Tyler love you Tyler
[Music]